[Musik]
bild key news
willkommen zurück bei bild live das sind
wirklich dramatische nachrichten die uns
heute erreicht haben sie fuhren ganz
normal streife jetzt sind zwei
polizisten tot eine 24-jährige und ihr
29 jähriger kollege kaltblütig
erschossen bei einer verkehrskontrolle
gegen 4.20 stoppen die beiden polizisten
auf der kreisstraße 22 uhr mit
rheinland-pfalz ein verdächtiges
fahrzeug per funk gaben sie durch das
sie im kofferraum totes wild gefunden
haben und jetzt eine kontrolle
durchführen würden na dann plötzlich kam
ein zweiter hektischer funkspruch die
schießen auf uns danach riss der kontakt
mit den polizisten ab kollegen fanden
die beiden dann leblos neben ihrem
fahrzeug ja und weil es hieß die
schießen auf uns gehen die ermittler
derzeit von mindestens zwei tätern aus
möglicherweise wilderer die waffen dabei
haben und hier ist das aktuelle
statement der polizei
ja um 420 hat eine polizeistreife
eine verkehrskontrolle im kreis kusel
angemeldet und kurz darauf haben die
kollegen gemeldet dass schüsse fallen
unterstützungskräfte sind dann quasi an
den ereignisort gefahren haben dort dann
aber eine kollegin und einen kollegen
verletzt bzw tot vorgefunden
beide kollegen wurden mittlerweile sind
mittlerweile verstorben kollegen haben
um 420 zwischen dem meierhof und uil mit
das liegt im kreis kusel eine
verkehrskontrolle angemeldet und kurz
darauf haben sie über funk mitgeteilt
dass schüsse fallen dann hatten wir
keinen funkkontakt mehr das heißt wir
wissen auch nicht was ist da passiert
sind einsatzkräfte an den ereignisort
gefahren haben aber die kollegen
verletzt bzw tot vorgefunden
beide einsatzkräfte eine kollegin 24
jahre alt und ein kollege 29 jahre alt
sind verstorben polizei schließt nicht
aus dass es mehrere täter gewesen sein
könnten also wir gehen derzeit davon aus
dass es mehrere gewesen sein könnten wir
können aber nicht mit gewissheit sagen
waren es 23 oder was am ende doch nur
einer da laufen einfach noch die
ermittlungen und die untersuchung und
das müssen wir abwarten
bild reporter thorsten kremers der ist
für uns live vor ort osten hast du
irgendwelche neuen erkenntnisse für uns
zu diesem wirklich tragischen fall
der polizeisprecher ist ja gerade eben
schon gesagt es wird in alle möglichen
richtungen im internet vor ort war heute
morgen schon nicht nur um sicherung für
uns an realen der absperrung sichtbar
aber auch sonst sind viele und in zwei
beamte der spurensicherung unterwegs in
diesem waldgebiet hinter mir da ist
übrigens auch noch ein gelände das
militär gehört also eine ziemlich
abgelegene des nation nicht hier in
diesem waldstück befindet sich einen
parkplatz trotzdem gegen polizisten nach
den aktuell vorliegenden informationen
mit einem zivilen fahrzeug vorgefahren
abend in kontrolle durchgeführt und die
polizei hat mittlerweile nach
unbestätigten berichten
einen ausweis gefunden wohl möglich den
ausweis eines täters
von uns anlegen außerdem ist
mittlerweile durchgesickert dass bei
dieser kontrolle
die polizistin gar keine chance mehr
hatte sich zu verteidigen die wache
steckte in ihrem holster also von der
gar nicht wert und mir gezogen werden
ein kollege hat es anscheinend so wie
ihr es gehört haben sein gesamtes
magazin leer geschossen bei der neben
wichtigen verteidigung aber sie sind
dann doch nicht gelungen den täter
zumindest so zu treffen dass man ihm an
jorge dann hätte noch festnehmen können
thorsten die täter sind auf der flucht
wie geht die bevölkerung damit um
ich habe mich umgehört die gute lage
sind alle sprachlos es ist auch
teilweise ein beklemmendes gefühl man
hat mir berichtet dieser parkplatz ist
auch öfters mal ein schauplatz anderer
kriminalfällen gewesen wohl gemeinsam
was an diesen platz stattgefunden abend
sollen aber auch andere
gestalten immer wieder mal bei
kontrollen auf den flüssen worden sind
das ist die erzählungen aus der
bevölkerung ja aber insgesamt muss man
auch sagen
man fühlt sich in orts gruseln dennoch
sicher im moment sowieso weil überall
ist polizei zu sehen es sind sehr viele
straßensperrungen und es ist dann auch
im benachbarten saarland eine fahndung
angelaufen also hier finden auch eine
unterstützung statt zudem sind auch
kräfte der militärpolizei hier vor ort
die extra von der airbase in ramstein
hierher geschickt wurden
dankeschön für diese ganz aktuellen
informationen wir wollen weiter schauen
zu bild chefreporter frank schneider
frank es ist wirklich ein unglaubliches
verbrechen kann man sagen dass
streifenpolizisten generell gefährlicher
leben
ja was heißt generell gefährlich aber
das problem ist dass streifenbeamte
immer wieder sie treten an autos heran
sie kontrollieren jeden tag fahrzeuge
sie kontrollieren personen fußgänger
auch fahrradfahrer und man weiß halt nie
was verbirgt sich dahinter und das ist
immer genau die gefahr von
streifenbeamte das natürlich auch
routine manchmal dazu führen kann dass
man eine situation unterschätzt aber
hier scheint es so gewesen zu sein dass
die täter dann wirklich in der nacht man
muss sich vorstellen eine einsame
landstraße 24 wir kontrollieren ein
fahrzeug da sind die beamten schon
sensibilisiert aber nach jetzigem stand
sieht es so aus dass die beamtin gar
keine chance mehr hatte zur gegenwehr
ihre pistole steckte noch im holster das
heißt die täter von denen die polizei
ausgeht mindestens zwei müssen
unvermittelt geschossen haben der beamte
hat das feuer noch erwidert hat dann
aber leider auch einen kopfschuss
erlitten und hatte auch keine chance
mehr sich in sicherheit zu bringen und
das zeigt eben dass streifenbeamte einer
unheimlichen gefahr ausgesetzt wir
kennen alle das sek die gehen genau
dahin wo terroristen geiselnehmer
schwerverbrecher mörder sind aber die
wissen dass die sind vorbereitet sie
haben eine ganz andere ausrüstung und
hier ist es so polizeibeamte in ganz
deutschland tragen mittlerweile
schusssichere westen in der regel unter
ihrer kleidung oder teilweise auch
darüber gezogen aber hier ist das
problem bei beiden scheint es sich um
eben kopfschüsse gehandelt zu haben
unterstützt nichts und sie trage nun mal
keinen helden das ist beim normalen
dienst nicht möglich im streifenwagen
nicht wir sehen jetzt die beiden die
eingesetzt sind mit ballistischen
schutzhelmen das ist die so genannte
amok terror ausrüstung die auf
streifenbeamte haben aber die müssen sie
extra anlegen und wenn sie nicht
vermuten dass sie beschossen werden
können insbesondere mit möglicherweise
langwaffen auch hier in diesem fall die
eine höhere durchschlagskraft haben dann
sind die beamten natürlich dieser gefahr
erst mal total ausgesetzt hat die gewalt
gegen polizisten generell zugenommen
naja die gewalt das sehen wir auch immer
wieder bei demonstrationen und ähnlichen
nimmt natürlich immer wieder zu es ist
ja auch jetzt unerträglich dass social
media teilweise leute da mehr oder
weniger sagen ja es sind sie ja selber
schuld so nach dem motto auch aus dieser
ecke wie wir das jetzt kennen von
rechtsradikalen und ähnlichen die dann
mehr oder weniger so was noch feiern das
ist unerträglich und man sieht eben
gewaltbereitschaft gegen polizeibeamte
nimmt immer weiter zu solche fälle muss
man natürlich sagen sind zum glück die
ausnahme dieses kaltblütige vorgehen
warum das jetzt so eskaliert ist in so
kurzer zeit das muss man sehen wenn dann
hoffentlich die täter bald gefasst sind
was ist der grund dafür
weil einfach so auf polizisten zu
schießen auch wenn es eben diese
vermutung gibt es könnten bilde gewesen
sein aber wenn ich ein wildschwein
schieße unerlaubt dann droht mir eine
geldstrafe deswegen kann ich doch nicht
zwei polizisten erschießen dann gehe ich
lebenslangen haft und zwar zu recht und
deswegen ist es jetzt noch völlig unklar
warum das so eskalieren konnte
möglicherweise hatten die
tatverdächtigen doch noch etwas auf dem
kerbholz dass wir alle nicht wissen oder
steckt nachher doch noch ein ganz
anderes motiv möglicherweise politisches
motiv dahinter man muss schon auch sagen
das ist wirklich besonders kaltblütig
wie diese täter hier offenbar
vorgegangen sind da kann man schon von
einer neuen qualität aussprechen frank
oder
absolut besonders weil beide eben
polizisten auch mit kopfschüssen getötet
wurden die beamtin offen aus kurzer
distanz ich habe ja eben beschrieben sie
hatte noch nicht mal mehr die chance
ihre waffe zu ziehen das zeigt dieses
unglaublich kaltblütige vorgehen
und das spricht ja dafür dass die täter
entweder irgendetwas zu verbergen hatten
oder gezielt die beamten töten wollen
und das muss man jetzt abwarten was wie
gesagt die ermittlungen ergeben man kann
nur hoffen dass diese wahnsinnige
großfahndung die gerade insbesondere
bereich rheinland pfalz und saarland
aber auch natürlich bundesweit läuft die
polizei dort wird mit allem unterstützt
was was möglich ist das sind
hubschrauber spürhunde drohen alles im
einsatz weil man natürlich schnell
versuchen möchte diese täter zu bekommen
denn es besteht ja die gefahr dass sie
möglicherweise weitere schwere
straftaten begehen denn eigentlich haben
sie jetzt nichts mehr zu verlieren sie
haben ihre unglaubliche
gewaltbereitschaft gezeigt auch dieses
eiskalte vorgehen und deshalb muss man
befürchten bevor sie sich festnehmen
lassen dass sie möglicherweise erneut um
sich schießen
wer genau gehen denn die beamten jetzt
tatsächlich bei der suche nach den
tätern vor kannst du uns mehr dazu sagen
ja das hauptproblem bei dieser tat ist
natürlich erstmal es fehlen die
sogenannten objektiven zeugen es ist
mitten irgendwo im wald mitten in der
nacht das ist die klassische uhrzeit
wenn so gut wie kein mensch mehr auf der
straße ist und deswegen fehlen natürlich
die zeugen die vielleicht ein
fluchtfahrzeug beobachtet haben die
etwas der polizei sagen können das
einzige was es momentan ist sind eben
diese kurzen funksprüche
daraus lässt sich aber auch keine
rückwirkung rückschlüsse ziehen auf die
flüchtenden täter und deswegen muss die
polizei jetzt versuchen auch grund auch
vielleicht über verkehrs
überwachungskameras oder ähnliches
auszuwerten gibt es vielleicht aufnahmen
wo wir das mögliche fluchtfahrzeug sehen
zum anderen werden natürlich die spuren
gesichert am tatort es gibt
möglicherweise patronenhülsen und das
muss jetzt alles ausgewertet werden es
gibt blutspuren am tatort möglicherweise
sind die täter auch getroffen worden
weil der eine beamte hat ja
zurückschießen können sie ein ganzes
magazin leer geschossen vielleicht ist
einer der täter auch verletzt worden und
dann können es auch blutspuren sein wenn
sie in der datenbank der polizei sind
möglicherweise vorbestraft sind dann
könnte man auch da rückschlüsse auf den
täter ziehen aber das dauert natürlich
und 1 hat die polizei natürlich momentan
nun gar nicht das ist zeitweilig habe es
eben beschrieben diese täter sind so
gefährlich die haben nichts mehr zu
verlieren
und deswegen ist es der polizei ihr
größtes ziel diese täter sofort zu
bekommen und dann werden aber definitiv
spezialeinsatzkräfte zum einsatz kommen
denn da kann man jetzt keine normalen
beamten hinschicken denn wie gesagt sie
haben unter beweis gestellt sie machen
mit der von der schusswaffe
rücksichtslos und sofort gebrauch die
polizei hat ja auch die bevölkerung vor
ort gewarnt sie hat gesagt keine
anhalter sollen mitgenommen werden wie
schätzt du die gefahr für die
bevölkerung ein momentan
das ist natürlich sehr schwer zu sagen
man muss jetzt erstmal davon ausgehen
dass die täter mit dem fahrzeug
geflüchtet sind es ist ja kein fahrzeug
gefunden worden trotzdem muss man
natürlich sagen ist ein waldgebiet ein
truppenübungsplatz in der nähe man kann
natürlich ein fahrzeug auch
möglicherweise ein paar kilometer
entfernt im wald abstellen verstecken
vielleicht versteckt man sich auch
selber dort weil man die gefahr sieht
dass man ja auf der flucht einem
streifenwagen der auch dorthin alarmiert
worden ist entgegenkommt gesehen wird
das kann man nie ausschließen in der
regel versuchen täter aber natürlich vom
tatort so schnell wie möglich weg zu
kommen und das ist natürlich in der
tiefen der nacht in seinem abgelegenen
gelände auch sehr gut möglich
möglicherweise zur nächsten autobahn und
da muss man abwarten
wohin sie am ende wirklich geflohen sind
deswegen ist ja auch die fahndung
ausgeweitet worden auf das benachbarte
saarland aber die gefahr jetzt zu sagen
es ist jetzt konkret dort gefährlich
oder woanders das ist nicht so aber die
polizei hat alles an verfügbaren kräften
auf der straße alles im bereich der
fahndung ist in hundertschaften im
einsatz auch die bundespolizei verstärkt
sogar die militärpolizei die feldjäger
unterstützen und ich glaube die polizei
wir natürlich absolut auf nummer sicher
gehen dass nicht noch weitere menschen
zu schaden kommen sobald es etwas neues
gibt erfahren wir es natürlich von dir
vielen dank für den moment frank
schneider
nun ganz deutschland ist natürlich
bestürzt nach dieser grausam nach dieser
kaltblütigen tat und es gibt inzwischen
auch erste reaktionen via twitter unter
anderem von innenministerin nancy faeser
unabhängig vom motiv diese tat erinnert
an eine hinrichtung und zeigt dass
polizei jeden tag leben für unsere
sicherheit riskiert meine gedanken sind
bei den familien freunden und kollegen
der opfer wir werden alles tun um die
täter dingfest zu machen so die
innenministerin auf twitter ja und auch
die ministerpräsidentin von rheinland
pfalz malu dreyer und innenminister
roger lewentz haben sich inzwischen auf
twitter zu wort gemeldet sie schreiben
unsere gedanken sind
bei den angehörigen und bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen der polizei in
falls die tat ist entsetzlich ist
bestürzt uns sehr dass zwei junge
menschen im dienst ihr leben verloren
haben
die polizei selbst die hält dann auch
die bevölkerung via twitter auf dem
laufenden natürlich wir haben es auch
gehört da geht jetzt die angst um bei
den menschen und deshalb wurde am
gasthaus steiner man nun extra eine art
krisen center eingerichtet dort gibt es
dann noch extra ansprechpartner für die
bevölkerung ja und von den tätern fehlt
bislang jede spur deshalb fahndet die
polizei weiter sucht immer noch zeugen
die angaben machen können sie sollen
sich unbedingt bei der polizei melden
und auch kleinste beobachtungen können
entscheidend sein
eine wirkliche unfassbare tat muss man
sagen wir wollen einmal noch einmal für
sie zusammenfassen was wir jetzt genau
wissen den aktuellen stand der
ermittlungen zwei polizisten also eine
erst 24 jährige und ein 29-jähriger
führten im landkreis kusel eine ganz
routinemäßige verkehrskontrolle durch
auf der kreisstraße 22
da fehlen dann gegen 4 uhr 20 die
tödlichen schüsse die polizisten hatten
keine chance sie konnten noch eine kurze
funkmeldungen absetzen hilfe kam aber
für beide leider gottes zu spät die
hintergründe sind noch völlig unklar die
polizei sicherheit immer noch spuren
fahndet mit hochdruck nach den tätern
und mindestens einer ist bewaffnet also
die polizei bittet darum im landkreis
kusel keine anhalter mitzunehmen
und natürlich bietet sie auch darum
vorsichtig zu sein zeugen die eventuell
irgendetwas gesehen haben werden gebeten
sich bei der polizei zu melden
jeder kleinste hinweis kann eventuell
entscheidend sein